I'd like to thank everyone for joining
me - a beginner's guide to chip my name
is David gradski I'm the epigenetics
specialists in scientific supported AB
chem for the Americas I'd now like to
start by introducing you to chip
chromatin immunoprecipitation or chip is
the selective enrichment of a chromatin
fraction containing a specific antigen
this antigen is a specific protein of
interest and you enrich for this protein
bound to DNA by pulling it down using an
antibody chip allows you to study gene
regulation by determining the
localization of a protein of interest
for instance a transcription factor in
the genome at all of its binding sites
and under specific conditions such as
different disease states or treatments
you can also compare enrichments of a
protein or protein modification such as
a histone modification at different loci
you can map the location of a protein of
interest across an entire locus you can
quantify a protein or protein
modification at an inducible gene over a
time course of course for chip the
starting template is chromatin which is
a protein and DNA complex whose basic
function is higher-order packaging of
DNA into the nucleus if all 3.2 billion
base pairs of DNA in the human genome
were unraveled it would stretch to
around 5 feet long so chromatin allows
all of the DNA to fit inside the nucleus
chromatin is also extremely important in
regulation of during gene transcription
the most basic unit of chromatin is the
nucleosome which consists of DNA wound
around a core of 8 histone proteins the
nucleosome core consists of
approximately 147 base pairs of DNA
wrapped around the octamer made up of
two copies each of histones h2a h2b h3
and h4 histone h1 and sits on top of
this structure to keep the wrapped DNA
in place more relaxed chromatin is
termed uh chromatin which tends to be
gene rich due to its open and
accessible structure as chromatin
condenses further and further it becomes
what is called heterochromatin which
contains repressed and silent low sigh
as well as repetitive elements finally
there is even higher level packaging to
form metaphase chromosomes during
mitosis here are classic electron
micrographs showing what chromatin looks
like with the distinctive beads on a
string structure on the left and more
compacted chromatin on the right now
here's a closer up view of the
nucleosome core with the eight histone
molecules and DNA tightly wrapped around
it the diameter of a nucleosome is
around 10 nanometers and histones are
unique in that they have n terminal
tails that stick out from the nucleosome
core whose residues are targeted for
modifications that's like different
roles in the regulation of chromatin
structure and therefore affect gene
transcription histone modifications
along with DNA methylation are the main
epigenetic mechanisms that control gene
transcription when a gene is switched on
and transcription is possible the
chromatin is open and relaxed so that
transcription factors and other binding
elements can bind freely to promoters
when a gene is switched off and
transcription is impeded the chromatin
structure is condensed so that these
factors can't bind to the DNA here is a
diagram of some of the different
modifications that occur on the histone
tails histones h3 and h4 are the most
commonly modified histones whose
residues are targeted for a set elation
methylation phosphorylation deamination
and ubiquitination a set elation is
generally associated with gene
activation and occurs mostly at promoter
regions while different and specific
methylation modifications are involved
with either gene activation or
repression by relaxing or condensing
chromatin for example guy and try
methylation of h3k4 and monomethylation
of h3
k9r associated with activation whereas
Dai and trimethylation of h3k27 and
trimethylation of h3k9 are associated
with repression deamination occurs when
an arginine residue is converted to a
citrulline residue phosphorylation has
roles in DNA repair transcriptional
regulation and chromosome condensation
and ubiquitination appears to play a
role in DNA repair I'd like to focus a
bit more on asset elation and
methylation as these modifications are
most commonly studied by chip a set
elation occurs on lysine residues and
there are specific enzymes that add or
remove settle groups to license histone
acetyltransferases and histone
deacetylases respectively on the right
you can see a representative chip
experiment using an h3k27 acetylene
tebah d this antibody specifically
recognizes histone h3 when its Isetta
lated at lysine 27 here we pull down DNA
that was bound to this histone
modification and performed qPCR using
primers for several different loci to
determine where the modification is
located you can see that this
modification is located at promoters of
genes that are constitutively active
such as gap d h RP l 30 and aldo a which
we expect since l set elation is
associated with gene activation we can
also see that this modification is not
present at inactive genes which we also
expect
similarly for methylation there are
enzymes that add or remove methyl groups
to lysines and arginines histone
methyltransferases and histone
demethylases on the right I'm showing a
chip experiment using an antibody
specific for histone h3 when it's tri
methylated at lysine 9 we find this
modification present at inactive genes
such as my OD and Sortino as well as it
heterochromatin while you can see that
it's mostly absent from active
assai of course chip isn't only for
histone proteins you can also use chip
to analyze the location of transcription
factors or other DNA binding proteins
here's a cartoon of RNA polymerase 2
which sits at the promoter along with
transcription factors and moves along
the DNA as transcription progresses if
you perform chip to see where RNA
polymerase 2 binds you can see strong
binding at active promoters such as
those of gap th and gamma actin and you
can see the polymerase along the entire
gamma actin gene as transcription
progresses as expected RNA polymerase is
not detected at inactive genes now I'd
like to go over the chip protocol in
depth here's an overview of the chip
protocol there are two main ways you can
do chip cross-linking chip which can be
used for any protein but must be used
for proteins that weakly bind to DNA and
native chip which can be performed when
analyzing histones I'll go into greater
detail about the two a bit later in
cross-linking chip DNA is cross-linked
to proteins typically using formaldehyde
cells are lysed and the DNA is then
fragmented by sonication into random
fragments of two hundred to a thousand
base pairs in native chip the DNA and
proteins are not cross-linked and micro
cockle nucleus is used to digest the DNA
which can produce DNA fragments at the
level of a single nucleus ohm or around
150 to 175 base pairs it is incredibly
important to start with the best
chromatin template as possible so the
first two steps are probably the most
important and must be optimized for each
experiment next a specific antibody of
interest is added to bind the protein
which is bound to DNA and this complex
is then immunoprecipitated pulling down
only DNA fragments that are directly
bound to the target protein cross links
are then reversed if you're doing
cross-linking chip and the DNA can be
purified for later analysis by PCR
hybridization to a microarray or
sequencing the abundance of DNA pulldown
can be compared to the input or starting
chromatin amount the first step in
cross-linking chip is to cross-linked
the DNA to proteins most commonly this
is done with formaldehyde which cross
links protein to DNA RNA and other
proteins less commonly chemicals such as
cisplatin can be used and cisplatin
cross links proteins to DNA only
ultraviolet light is also a cross linker
but is not used in chip only an RNA
amino precipitation or cross-linking
amino precipitation to analyze protein
interactions with RNA cross-linking
fixes molecular interactions and freezes
them at a given point in time
importantly formaldehyde creates
reversible cross links and typically
you'll use a convert concentration of
0.75 to 1.5% for 2 to 30 minutes it's
important to perform a time course to
see what cross-linking time gives you
the best result it's important to keep
in mind that if you cross link for too
long this can lead to the reduction of
antigen accessibility altered epitopes
and a decrease in protein binding
whereas if you don't cross-linked enough
the proteins will dissociate from the
DNA next whether you're doing
cross-linking chip or native chip you
need to fragment the DNA into smaller
sizes DNA fragmentation is important
because it makes the chromatin soluble
and the DNA fragment size determines the
mapping of the target antigen if your
fragment size is too large you could be
pulling down a protein that's far away
from your actual DNA region of interest
so this step requires optimization you
should try different sonication times
for cross-linking chip and different
concentrations of micro cockell nucleus
for native chip after sonication or
enzymatic digestion you should remove
some chromatin reverse the cross links
and to purify the DNA to run in the gel
alongside a DNA ladder as shown in this
figure to determine what condition gives
you the most appropriate sized fragments
you're ideally looking for fragments of
two hundred to a thousand base pairs by
sonication or around 175 base pairs by
enzyme keep in mind the efficiency of
sonication is affected by foam cell
density the cross-linking time and the
cell type you're working with the next
step is the immuno precipitation this is
where you add a specific antibody to
bind the protein bound to DNA and then
pull it down the amount of antibody
needs to be optimized and chip typically
requires a large amount of antibody
anywhere from one to ten micrograms next
you add protein a/g
or a combination of protein a and g
beads that will bind to the antibody
these can either be a gross which you'd
centrifuge or magnetic which would we
pull down in a magnetic tube rack next
there are several wash steps to remove
nonspecific binding finally you need to
recover the DNA that was pulled down as
part of the antibody protein complex
first you will loot the antibody from
the beads using SDS and heat then you
reverse the cross-links if you're
performing cross-linking chip this is
done with salt and heat next the
proteins in RNA gets degraded using
proteinase k and RNA sa and finally
you'll purify the DNA using a phenol
chloroform extraction or a PCR
purification kit be sure to include your
input sample in all of these DNA
recovery steps
next comes the downstream analysis to
determine what the sequences of DNA got
pulled down
this is done with qpcr chip on chip or
chip seek i've already showed some
examples of qpcr data keep in mind that
when you use qPCR you need to have
target low SCI in mind and you need to
design primers for the amplification
chip on chip and chip seek allow you to
perform chip on a genome-wide scale in
chip on chip the chip procedure is
carried out as it normally would be
until after the DNA is purified
at this point the immunoprecipitated DNA
is amplified and labeled fluorescently
the input DNA is also amplified and
labeled with a complementary fluorescent
probe and both sets of label DNA are
combined and hybridized to microarrays
corresponding to specific domains loci
of interest or the whole genome the
ratio of signal from the fluorescent
labels of the chip DNA and control DNA
allows enriched regions to be identified
there are some limitations of chip on
chip though as technology advances these
are becoming less of an issue the first
is that a large number of cells are
required for chip on chip experiments
chip on chip is also not sensitive to
all of the repetitive elements in the
human genome a large number of arrays
are necessary to cover the entire genome
and finally chip on chip could be
susceptible to amplification bias after
the DNA amplification more commonly
chips seek is used to analyze protein
DNA binding interactions on a
genome-wide scale in chip seek the
pull-down DNA sequences are purified and
amplified followed by high-throughput
sequencing of the fragments these
sequinsed fragments then get mapped and
aligned to the genome and if there are
many sequenced fragments that overlap at
a specific spot they form a peak these
Peaks indicate that this sequence was
bound to the protein that got pulled
down by the antibody here's an example
of what the peaks look like in these
sequencing tracks from a publication
that was looking at histone
modifications genome-wide here they're
showing results from a region with two
active genes stat1 and stat2 region
containing an inactive gene Myo 1b you
can see that activating histone marks
such as h3k4 methylation at the top left
are present at the active genes
especially as the gene promoters but are
absent from the repressed gene similarly
if you look at marks of repression such
as h3k27 and
three canine died and trimethylation you
can see that these modifications are
found along the inactive my o1b gene to
show how powerful chip is I'd like to
show this figure from the same
publication here the author's created a
high-resolution map of histone
modifications on a genome-wide scale
they correlated histone modifications
and several other proteins such as RNA
polymerase 2 in around 13,000 genes in
resting human cd4 positive T cells whose
expression levels are known they
separated the genes into groups based on
their expression levels either high
medium low or silent genes as indicated
by the different colors and align them
relative to the transcription start
sites we can see the binding of RNA
polymerase 2 right at the transcription
start site we can see the binding of RNA
polymerase 2 right at the transcription
start site of the active genes and if we
look at the histone modification we can
see a nucleosome depleted region right
at the transcription start site where no
histones are bound with the marks of
activation h3k4 methylation present
around the start site and active genes
and the mark of repression h3k27
trimethylation genes all of this chip
data has allowed us to see exactly which
and where histone modifications are
present along an entire active gene as
well as an inactive genes which I'm not
showing here when transcription is
happening histone modifiers introduce
activating histone modifications as the
polymerase travels along the DNA the
promoter region has a very well-defined
chromatin signature there's a clear
nucleosomes depleted region where the
polymerase binds and large increases in
activating h3k4 trump methylation and a
settle a tion as transcription continues
along the gene modifiers introduce new
modifications to allow the polymerase to
move along the
DNA I hope these few examples show how
powerful and useful chip can be now I'd
like to spend some time going over
protocol optimization and
troubleshooting as I mentioned earlier
there is native chip and cross-linking
chip and each has its own advantages and
disadvantages with native chip you
typically get more efficient
precipitation of the DNA and protein as
well as greater specificity because the
binding is more predictable you also
have higher resolution as low as a
single nucleus ohm compared to 200 to
1000 base pair fragments you get with
sonication the disadvantages of native
chip include the fact that it's only for
histone proteins because the DNA is
tightly interacting with these proteins
if you want to do chip of transcription
factors since they're binding to DNA is
not strong you'll have to cross link to
ensure the protein DNA interactions
intact another disadvantage is that
since the nuclease digestion is
selective the digestion may bias input
chromatin and there are also chances of
chromatin rearrangement and of course if
you use too much nucleus you could over
digest the chromatin cross-linking chip
on the other hand is much more flexible
and can be performed with histone and
non-histone proteins on all cell types
tissues and organisms in addition to DNA
protein analysis you can also analyze
RNA protein and higher order protein
protein DNA interactions and there is a
reduced chance of chromatin
rearrangements there are of course
several disadvantages of cross-linking
chip including the fact that over
fixation can prevent effective
sonication enzymatic suggestion won't be
possible after formaldehyde treatment
formaldehydes can alter the binding of
the antigen and it has a lower
resolution the native chip since you
can't use micro Cockell nucleus for
digestion hopefully this will help
determine if native or cross-linking
chip is more appropriate for your
experiment I'll start with optimizing
your protocol by going over how to
choose the right antibody
most antibodies will not work for chip
so a good place to start is to look for
antibodies that have been fully
characterized for chip you should also
look for specificity testing such as
peptide array data here is that h3k4
trimethylation buddy i showed earlier
and we can see the antibody is binding
strongly only to the k4 tri methyl or no
binding to these other peptides tested
in the array indicating the antibody is
specific for the tri methyl k4
modification we're developing new highly
specific rabbit monoclonal antibodies
that are all specificity tested by a new
peptide array whose data is available on
every datasheet this peptide array
contains 501 different modified and
unmodified peptides and each peptide is
printed on the array at 6 concentrations
the circles represent the affinity
between the antibody and a peptide red
circles show binding to the antigen
containing peptides
well non antigen containing peptides are
in blue you can click on a link for more
data showing what each peptide is and
all of the batches of our chip
antibodies are tested by peptide array
if an antibody is not tested for chip
but you're interested in trying it out
look for antibodies that have been
tested for immuno precipitation
immunohistochemistry or amino saito
chemistry these applications recognize
the proteins native conformation
similarly to chip rather than a Western
blot only antibody that might only
recognize a protein in its denatured
form if you'd like to test one of ab
cams antibodies and chip you can use our
ab trial testing program which I'll
discuss more later finally with regards
to clone ality polyclonal and monoclonal
antibodies both have advantages and
disadvantages polyclonal antibodies
recognize several epitopes which is
great for cross-linking chip where
epitopes might become masked but they do
have some batch to batch variation
monoclonal antibodies recognize only a
single epitope so if the epitope is
masked
the antibody won't bind but there is
very minimal batch to batch variation
look out for our new rabbit monoclonal
antibodies for chip as I mentioned
earlier probably the most important step
in optimizing your chip protocol is
beginning with a really good chromatin
template and the correct fragment size
for cross-linking chip this involves
finding the appropriate cross-linking
and sharing time and for native chip
this involves finding the appropriate
amount of enzyme and digestion time you
should perform a time course to
determine the right amount of time to
crosslink which could be anywhere from 2
to 30 minutes but 10 to 15 minutes is
usually sufficient if you're looking at
protein DNA interactions that are
mediated by other proteins and are not
directly bound to DNA you may need to
try a dual cross-linking strategy where
you cross link with the combination of
formaldehyde as well as an additional
cross-linking chemical such as eg s or
DSG getting the right fragment sizes of
most important you must try different
sonication times and then purify DNA to
run in the gel to figure out what
sonication time will get you the most
appropriate size you typically want
fragment sizes of two hundred to a
thousand base pairs for native chip you
can get fragments of around 175 base
pairs next you should determine the
proper amount of antibody to use for
your chip typically around four
micrograms of antibody per 25 micrograms
of chromatin is appropriate but the
antibody should be tired to improve the
signal-to-noise ratio the composition of
your wash buffers is important you
should determine the appropriate amount
of sodium and lithium chloride to
provide the appropriate stringency this
could be from 250 to 500 milli molar
having a wash buffer that isn't
stringent enough will lead to high
background while a buffer that is too
harsh will destroy specific antibody
interaction
since chip is difficult and
time-consuming to perform it's very
important to have the right control to
determine if the experiment worked
properly these include a negative IP
control which would be an ISO type IgG
control or beads only positive and
negative control low sigh for qpcr which
would be a region or gene where you know
a protein should be bound and shouldn't
be bound and a non template control for
qPCR to make sure there's no
contamination in your PCR positive
control antibodies are extremely
important if you're looking at an active
locus you can use antibodies that
recognize h3k4 trimethylation through
canine a settle for instance and if
you're looking at a repressed locus you
can use antibodies that recognize h3k9
try methyl or h3k27 trimethylation h3
antibody which should be present
everywhere here you can see the presence
of h3k4 trimethylation h3k9 tri methyl
at heterochromatin now on to
troubleshooting what if you have high
background in your nonspecific antibody
control so this would be either your
isotype IgG control or beads only tubes
there could be nonspecific binding to
the beads so I always recommend
including a pre clearing step you could
have contaminated wash buffers so it's
good practice to always use fresh
buffers or replace your buffers if
you're getting high background and some
beads inherently have high background so
it's good to try different beads and
different blocking strategies to see
which provide the lowest background in
the nonspecific control what if you have
low resolution with high background
across large regions this is most likely
due to the DNA fragment size being too
large fragments should definitely not be
larger than one and a half kilobases and
ideally should be between two hundred to
a thousand base pairs and keep in mind
if you're able to do native chip you can
get the best resolution of a single
nucleosome what if you're getting low or
no signal well lots of things could be
wrong the DNA fragment size could be too
small
so make sure you run your fragments on a
gel to see if they're the correct size
if you're performing cross-linking chip
the cells may have been cross-linked for
too long which can reduce the
availability of epitopes so be sure to
perform a time course and quench with
glycine it could be that you don't have
enough starting material chip generally
requires a large starting input around
25 micrograms of chromatin per IP or 3
to 4 million cells per IP you could also
not have used enough antibody three to
five micrograms is usually sufficient
but up to ten micrograms might be
required if there's low or no signal you
could be eliminating the specific
antibody binding if your wash buffers
are too stringent so don't use more than
five hundred milli molar of sodium or
lithium chloride make sure your cells
are sufficiently lysed
something like a ripple buffer should
work well keep in mind that your Brazil
keep in mind that your result might be
real if there's no antibody enrichment
at the region of interest so be sure to
include a positive control antibody and
locus to ensure the chip is working make
sure you know when to use native versus
cross-linking chip cross-linking chip is
more suitable when analyzing proteins
that have weaker DNA affinity so
cross-linking will be required to keep
proteins associated with DNA and native
chip can really only be performed if
you're looking at histones if you're
using a monoclonal antibody it may not
be suitable for cross-linking chip due
to epitope masking so try an antibody
that's tested for chip or a polyclonal
antibody and make sure you're using the
correct affinity beads so make sure the
antibody species and immunoglobulin bind
to the chosen beads or use a protein a/g
mix what about problems with the PCR
amplification if you're getting high
signal in all of your samples after PCR
including the non template control your
PCR solutions may be contaminated so you
should use new solutions and if you're
getting no amplification in your samples
be sure to include a standard or input
DNA
to confirm the primers are working if
you're performing or planning to do chip
seek and need help with the analysis we
have a step-by-step guide to chip seek
data analysis webinar available to watch
at any time on our website you can find
it under scientific webinars in the
events section of our homepage or by
navigating to the website listed here
I'd like to turn now to the resources AB
cam provides to help scientists with
their research I mentioned the AB trial
program earlier this is a program where
you can use our products in an untested
application or species without financial
risk this is a great program if you'd
like to try out one of our untested
antibodies in chip if you send us your
results in an AB review whether they're
positive or negative we'll send you a
discount code for the full value of the
product that can be used on a future
order if you'd like to enroll in this
program you can visit ab cam comm / ab
trial or contact our scientific support
department we also have our app reviews
program these are user reviews from
customers like yourself that show
whether or not a product works and
exactly what they did to get the product
to work you can submit a review for any
of our products on a scale of one to
five stars and we publish all of them
good and bad here you can see this h3k9
settle antibody has 32 reviews and if
you click on the circled link you're
able to filter the reviews by
application species and by rating and
you can see the specific protocol
information and an image for each review
we also gather references for all of our
products when we find them or hear about
them from customers we make them easy to
access on every datasheet by clicking
the circled link you can see this
antibody has 88 references and when you
click the link it gives you a list of
the publications with the convenient
link directly to the PubMed entry as
well as the application and species that
the antibody was used in AB cam also has
many products for your epigenetics
research we're knock-out validating our
antibodies see
you can be sure that these antibodies
are specific we're using CRISPR cast 9
technology to completely knock out the
gene in haploid cell lines these
antibodies are easy to find on our
website you can just search for knockout
you can filter for knockout validated
antibodies on the left side of the
search page if you're looking for a
specific target and all of these
antibodies have this ko validated logo
we're showing the knockout data on all
of the antibody data sheets in this
western blot for akt1 you can see in the
right panel the wild-type sample has a
band that they expect molecular weight
and the band is gone in the knockout
samples beta-actin is used as a loading
control we're also performing immuno
Saito chemistry as you can see here with
this ki-67 antibody the signal is gone
in the knockout samples in the lower
right hand quadrant we also have over
200 kits for studying different
epigenetic mechanisms for sample
preparation we offer chromatin histone
and nuclear extraction kits as well as
DNA extraction kits for whole cell
genomic DNA formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded DNA urine DNA and
plasma and serum DNA if you're studying
DNA methylation we have kits for
bisulfite conversion bisulfite
sequencing 5 MC and 5hmc quantification
methylated DNA preparation and
methylated DNA immuno precipitation and
hydroxy methylated DNA immuno
precipitation for RNA methylation we
have RNA by sulphide conversion kits and
m6a methylation quantification kids for
chromatin analysis we offer chip and
chip seat kits as well as kits to
analyze histone modifications such as H
deck and sirtuin assays a set elation
methylation and demethylation
quantification kits and kits to measure
histone phosphorylation if you're
studying micro rna's we have our firefly
multiplex micro RNA profiling platform
which you can find a ton of information
about on our website
finally we are here to help if you ever
have questions or problems with our
products don't hesitate to contact us by
email or phone we offer support around
the globe and in many different
languages also keep in mind that all of
our products are covered by our app
promise guarantee if you're using a
product in a tested application and
species and it's not working as it says
it should on the datasheet just let us
know and we'll help you get the product
working or give you a replacement or
refund to contact us just click the
contact us link at the top of our
website or email us here I'd like to
thank everyone for watching